if all u.s citizens had access to
medicare the government's medical
insurance program for the elderly would
the u.s have been in a better position
to handle the covet 19 pandemic or would
it have
only made matters worse that was the
subject of an
online solo forum debate held on
wednesday august 19
2020. arguing in favor of medicare for
all was university of massachusetts at
amherst
economics professor gerald friedman
author of the book
the case for medicare for all he went up
against sally pipes
president of the pacific research
institute and author of
false premise false promise the
disastrous reality of medicare for all
here's gerald friedman and sally pipes
in an online debate
moderated by soho forum director gene
epstein
the resolution reads the covid 19
pandemic
makes it all the more urgent for the u.s
to install
a system of medicare for all defending
the resolution university of
massachusetts
economics professor gerald friedman
opposing the resolution
sally pipes of the pacific research
institute
i'll be keeping track of the time and
will be briefly
interrupting each debater to say when he
or she
has five minutes left and one minute
left
jerry you're first up to defend the
resolution
the covet 19 pandemic makes it all the
more urgent
for the u.s to install a system of
medicare for all
jane please close the initial vote
and take it away jerry ah thank you
uh thank you all so much for having me
um
i'm particularly honored to be
discussing this topic with sally pipes
um i've been reading her work including
criticisms of some of my work for years
and come to respect her as an honest
critic
and a sophisticated analyst of health
policy
so i think this should be fun like the
best criticisms of
medicare for all whether in the time of
covert or before
uh pipes's critique comes in three parts
economic theory empirical analysis
and case studies while the book
integrates these three i'm going to pull
them apart here
discuss each separately and then zero in
on the implications
of the covid crisis case studies first
of all make great rhetoric
and but can be a bad guide to policy
ms pipes gives us examples of people
mistreated by canadian or british health
authorities i give examples of people in
the united states
denied care by insurance companies or
due to the inability to pay
for adequate insurance trading examples
can make for fun but by itself it's a
fruitless practice
these are large countries case studies
anecdotes become useful only when they
point to essential features of the
health care system
what i get from ms pipes's examples are
hard decisions made by administrators
responsible for the efficient use
of taxpayer resources and perhaps
mistakes these examples can make for a
good argument for reforming government
process or they can make for an argument
for maintaining access to a private
health care system a point by the way
where she and i are in agreement
notwithstanding the views of some of my
friends in the single-payer movement
the real question is whether these
stories are representative a question
that can only be answered with
statistics
like those that i'll be presenting in a
minute um
indeed i will demonstrate here that the
examples i
use like the tragic story of alex smith
and other diabetics
unable to afford insulin a story that i
tell at the beginning of my book
our representative the millions of
americans shut out of health care by
lack of insurance or inadequate
insurance is not an
accident not a mistake but the
consequence of a for-profit health care
system
a market-driven system favored by ms
pipes this leads me
to economic theory my favorite topic
and the core of msp types is critique
yes as she says economists live in a
world of scarcity
where she goes wrong isn't assuming that
a free market
will minimize and allocate scarcity
efficiently
subject only to the constraints of
factor endowments technology and
individual preferences
you have to throw those three in
whatever the merits of this assumption
in other markets this is not the case in
health care
health economics is a relatively new
field
uh dating back only to a 1963 article by
the socialist
single-payer supporter and nobel
laureate kenneth arrow
he was also my teacher one of the most
widely cited articles in economics
although i i suspect this article is
rarely read by the people who are citing
it
it's a true classic in that way arrow
demonstrates three crucial
points coming from uncertainty and
information asymmetries in health care
providers exercise monopoly power
individuals seek insurance even at
inflated prices
and for-profit insurance companies will
use control of information
to engage in adverse selection and
obstructive practices restricting
access and denying valued coverage the
result
is a market with inflated prices and
constrained supply
does that sound familiar if economic
theory does not provide the support
pipes assumes neither does empirical
experience far from exposing the failure
of social insurance systems such as the
canadian or the british systems
50 years of practice demonstrates the
abject failure
of private health insurance in the
united states to control costs or to
provide adequate care
this can be demonstrated in a few simple
graphs which are coming up
comparing course and health outcomes in
the united states with other affluent
members of the oecd organization of
economic cooperation development
both in cross-section at the same time
and longitudinally
over time u.s health care spending
is way above other countries increasing
faster
and producing fewer gains in life
expectancy
than in other countries these outcomes
are a direct result of the failure
of our for-profit market-driven
healthcare
okay and at this point i'm going to
shift into
my graphs um my
well i don't know maybe my favorite part
okay problems with u.s healthcare this
graph
should be pretty familiar to anybody
who's looked into this at all
life expectancy and healthcare spending
in the oecd
each diamond here represents a country
the vertical axis is life expectancy the
horizontal axis is the logarithm
of per capita spending the united states
is notable not only are we spending 50
percent more than any other country
but we're getting health care outcomes
everywhere else
you spend more you live longer the
united states this is true by the way
within
states of the united states but it's not
true for the united states compared to
other countries
we spend more we don't get the life
expectancy
um we're short six years in our life
expectancy compared to what we should
have
or we're spending seven thousand dollars
too much
compared with countries with comparable
life expectancy to
what we have um what's more this problem
is getting worse it wasn't so
true in 1970 when we were like one and a
half years behind canada in life
expectancy
but it's gotten more we're falling
behind
while at the same time that we're
falling behind in life expectancy we're
spending
more and more another way to look at it
is here
how much do we have to spend in the
united states to get one more year of
life expectancy
in other countries it's around four
hundred dollars canada three hundred
eighty dollars
um the uk 409 dollars
germany 398 dollars norway's
not so good um the netherlands
bit more but the united states well over
twelve hundred dollars
we are spending way more than other
countries to get
smaller gains in life expectancy um
and you know okay some of this you know
you could argue oh life expectancy
numbers are pulled down by
high infant mortality which maybe is due
to the way we counted in the united
states
i would argue about that but that's not
important whatever you look at
well not anything we actually have very
good trauma
survival rates we have very good trauma
centers in this country we've had a lot
of practice we fight a lot of wars
and we have a lot of internal violence
but
for most other illnesses
we have worse outcomes look at
maternal mortality this is a clear-cut
issue you don't want mothers to die in
labor
but we have over twice the maternal
mortality of slovakia
almost twice slovenia where i think the
president's wife came from
compared to canada twice as high
maternal mortality
this is a real failure of our health
care system
now so why is it so expensive and why
are we doing so badly
we kind of all know the answers
administrative cost
and the high price of health care in the
united states
we pay more for the same things uh part
of this is the administrative burden
and it's not that we're bad at
administering
we're good at that actually the share of
spending within public insurance or
private insurance spent on
administration
is less in the united states than in
other countries
but the problem is we have so much more
private insurance and private insurance
requires more administration
than public insurance in the united
states or in other countries
it's not that we go to the doctor too
much we don't
we go to the doctor less than do people
in other countries we go only a third as
often as the japanese who have
just about the longest life expectancy
of anybody they go once a month
um we go three four times a year
our drug prices are high this is not
just my numbers for medicare for all
this
you could go to the trump
administration's council of economic
advisors generally i would not recommend
you do that
but they say drug prices are twice as
high
as in the united states as elsewhere and
it's a
problem that's getting worse as well as
being
increasing you know so almost recent
but with the consolidation of the
hospital industry something that's been
exploding with the formation of these
giant networks
they're driving up their prices but not
to everybody
they're not driving up their prices to
medicare
medicare unlike private health insurance
has been able to contain
cost increases um at just about the
canadian rate
you know in canada since 1971 healthcare
costs have risen pretty much with the
cost of living
there's been really no increase in the
medicare
sorry in the medical cost index in
canada
relative to other prices the united
states
costs have risen over one and a half
percent a year relative to other prices
that is entirely in the private health
insurance sector
it is not true for medicare and it's not
true for medicaid medicaid's kind of
another issue
they need to spend more on that
so how have we tried to contain costs
given that prices are going up an
administrative burden is
um is heavy we do it by restricting
access a third of americans reported
that they could not
do some medical procedure in the last
year
almost three times the rate for other
countries
talk about weightless the u.s is where
we have weightless
um 18 did not fill a prescription
uh compared to 10 in canada where as
ms pipes knows uh many provinces don't
have
um public insurance for uh
pharmaceuticals
um compared to the uk two percent
in the uk did not fill a prescription um
over 20 of americans did not go to the
doctor because of cost
and what happens when you don't go to
the doctor you know what you die
every circle here is a county in the
united states over three thousand
counties
the horizontal axis is the proportion in
the county you could not see a doctor
because of course
vertical access is the age-adjusted
mortality rate
counties where more people did not go to
the doctor because of course
have higher mortality this accounts for
10
of mortality in the united states the r
squared is good the f statistic's
significant
this is a very powerful regression um
you could
fuss with it by adding a few other
variables i've played with it some but
that coefficient is pretty robust
um okay so how can we cover more people
i estimate that if we had medicaid for
all
there'd be a 10 increase in medical
utilization
um blah house has an 11 increase you
know we're kind of in
yeah that's fine um
less billing and insurance related
activities
bir that accounts for 14 of total
provider spending now
much less for the public sector billing
the ama reports that had eight percent
of physician time is spent talking to
insurance companies
virtually all having to do with private
insurance
move everybody to a common system
every five minutes thank you move
everybody to a private uh to a public
a single public insurance system they
will free up enough time it will free up
nurse time and it will draw doctors back
into the medical profession
who have been suffering burnout an
increasing
problem in the american medical system
um reducing monopoly rents and
administrative waste
will save more money than the cost of
expanding coverage
if we can afford the current system we
could certainly afford something cheaper
now kovit has exposed
all the problems in our health care
system
and i'll highlight three points here
first we have a black swan
type event the pandemic exposes
the limits of the various insurance
measures
the reserves that have been built up by
hospitals by provider organizations
and by insurance companies
all of whom have been going to the
government as the insurer of la
or the re-insurer of last resort
we are already having to bail out
the private system because reasonably
they didn't think this would happen
and they didn't prepare for it second
the economic crisis that has come from
copit
means more people of hostile insurance
tens of millions of americans have lost
health insurance in the last four months
um just when they need it most
and why do we care that they need it
because
here's the third point we have a
communicable disease
i want my neighbors to get the health
care that will
allow them to not spread the virus to me
i'm totally selfish
i don't want to get sick i don't want my
neighbor to give me the virus
to avoid that i want that person
to have health insurance and to have
access to health care
medicare for all will make sure that
they have that health care
health care as a human right is
economically
efficient and that is the case for
medicare for all
so thank you very much okay thank you
jerry you uh
you came in under your allotted time but
uh you know that
that's a deadweight loss sally uh you
are arguing for the negative taking away
sally well first i'd like to thank gene
epstein and the soho forum for hosting
this event and inviting me to be part of
it
and i'd also like to thank professor
jerry friedman who i've read a lot of
his work over the years too
for what i'm sure is going to be a
product of good faith exchange of ideas
we're all professional
uh in this debate the question before us
is
whether covid19 makes it all the more
urgent for the u.s to install
a system of medicare for all that
question assumes medicare for all
is something we should want in the first
place and i guess i reject that premise
to explain why i'd like to address the
most common justification one hears for
medicare for all one that
jerry just mentioned the ideas
proponents assert
that health care is a universal right as
such
it should be provided by the government
for free to everyone everywhere
on the surface declaring healthcare a
right seems reasonable
the idea is not new you can find it as
far back as the united nations universal
declaration of human rights over the
years many prominent leaders on the left
from senator ted kennedy
to current vermont senator bernie
sanders they've tried to
formulate a right to health care but
this notion
is based on a fundamental category error
health care isn't a right
health care is a good and a service just
like every other good and service in a
market economy
it is scarce there is a finite amount of
it apportioning this finite amount
inevitably requires trade-offs those who
say that healthcare is a right
ignore this reality the view raises
fraught
intractable questions that don't have
easy or satisfactory answers
does the right to health care entitle
everyone to seek treatment from the very
best doctors or at the very best
hospitals
to ensure equal protection of a right to
health care would the government have
the right to ban people from paying
extra for better treatment
perhaps top-notch facilities would be
prevented from
offering innovative procedures and
instead compelled to offer a suite
of government-sanctioned services this
puts the government in a bind as well
if there's a million dollar pill that
can cure a group of patients
but the government can't afford to give
it to them all what do we do
in countries with single-payer systems
equality
often takes precedence over health and
therefore no one gets the pill
on the other hand once we accept health
care as a set of goods and services
as opposed to an abstract right the
question before us becomes
far more concrete how do we make finite
health care resources
as widely available as possible without
sacrificing
quality or imposing unreasonable
potentially crippling costs on our
government and on the economy
this is the question at the heart of
healthcare policy for proponents of
medicare for all
the answer to that question is clear we
must completely abolish health
private health coverage and replace it
with a government-run insurance scheme
so let's evaluate that answer not as a
moral proposition
but as a matter of public policy once we
do
it becomes clear that almost on almost
every important measure
this radical approach would do a worse
job than the market-based system we
already have
a system as i know is far from perfect i
wanted to add
let's start with cost there is no
denying as jerry said that the united
states pays more for health care per
capita
than any country in the world u.s health
expect care expenditures
total 17.7 of gross domestic product
in canada health care spending is 11.6
percent of gdp
the government has a monopoly on
covering everything deemed
medically necessary and they set a
global budget
tapping how much it will spend on health
care out-of-pocket spending by canadians
accounts for about 14
of our health care tab in the uk
health spending is a bit under 10
percent of gdp
people can purchase in the uk
supplemental private insurance
and about 10 percent do nearly 16
of health spending comes out of
britain's own pockets
it's tempting to look at this disparity
and surmise that countries
with single-payer systems have
discovered some secret
for lowering health care costs one that
america would be foolish
not to copy but for the most part the
only secret that they've discovered
is that governments can dictate what
they'll pay for healthcare
and there's little providers can do
about that
and this helps explain why physicians in
countries with government-run health
systems
earn less than their counterparts in the
us
american doctors earned 313 000
on average last year british doctors
earned less than half that
according to research from the
commonwealth fund primary care doctors
in the u.s made an average of 218 000 in
2016 nearly 50 percent more than their
canadian counterparts
and nearly 63 more than british doctors
but is paying doctors less a practice
america should emulate
after all lower salaries have helped
fuel
chronic doctor shortages throughout the
british system
in some practices the care of 11 000
patients is left to just one
general practitioner or what we call
primary care dog these shortages
are poised to get even worse once the
kobit 19 pandemic subsides
a june survey of british doctors found
that 14 percent
plan to leave the profession retire or
leave the national health service
britain's version of medicare for all
when things return to normal
canada faces a similar doctor shortage
last year an estimated 175
000 people in the country's four eastern
most provinces
were waiting to be matched with a family
doctor
america's public insurance programs
medicare and medicaid
already underpay health care providers
hospitals receive 87 cents for every
dollar they spend
creating medicare patients medicaid's
reimbursement rates for physicians
or even less than medicare's on average
about 72 percent of medicare
according to the kaiser family
foundation patients covered
by these programs account for a huge
share of the patient population
medicare has nearly 60 million
beneficiaries about 1
6 of our population medicaid has 65
million beneficiaries
one-fifth of our population it's no
wonder that one
out of every three primary care docs in
this country is
unwilling to accept medicaid patients
according to a recent survey
they can't afford to if these
underpayments become universal in the
u.s
doctors would leave the profession or
retire early
promising bright young people who would
never go to medical school in the first
place
and patients would struggle to find
timely care a report from
fti consulting estimates that estimates
that pay cuts resulting from medicare
for all
could shrink america's physician supply
by more than forty four thousand
by twenty fifty one would think the cut
rate prices paid in single-payer systems
would benefit government finances
freeing up resources for other vital
public sector priorities
in fact despite having enormous power to
underpaid providers
single-payer systems have proven a
fiscal nightmare
the world over britain's national health
service has been a near constant state
of crisis for decades
even as it has consumed an increasing
share of taxpayer funds
in the 50s nhs spending accounted for
just over 11 percent of the nation's
budget
by 2018 over 30 percent of all public
sector spending
went to the program in canada more money
is spent on health care than on any
other budget item
in every single province in some
provinces well over 40 percent of all
spending goes towards health care
not even this is enough to keep up with
the near endless demand for medical care
single-payer systems invariably generate
nor is single-payer such a great deal
for patients
two of these systems might save citizens
from having to pay for their healthcare
at the point of service
at least some of the time but patients
end up paying for care indirectly
through higher taxes great britain has
broadly higher income tax rates than
does the u.s
each canadian province forces at least
some of its residents to pay double
income tax rates
that and that is of course on top of the
federal rates
all told the average canadian family of
four
pays thirteen thousand three hundred and
eleven dollars
in hidden taxes just for public health
coverage according to the fraser
institute
so the idea that single payer provides
free health care
is just fiction but let's move beyond
dollars and cents and discuss what it's
like for patients in a single-payer
system
as someone who was born in canada i can
speak with some authority
in my homeland government rationing of
health care is a fact of life
in 2019 a typical canadian seeking care
from a specialist waited nearly 21 weeks
five months between seeing a primary
care doc and getting treatment by a
specialist
patients in some provinces routinely
wait more than 30 weeks
for treatment in 2018 canadians were
waiting for nearly 1.1 million
procedures
if you assume one patient per procedure
that means three percent of the
population of 35 million was on a
waiting list
extrapolate those numbers to the u.s and
that's the equivalent of more than 9.8
million americans would be waiting for
care
britain's nhs is no better a february
report from the house of commons library
revealed the share of emergency room
patients waiting more than four hours
for care has risen roughly five-fold
since 2011.
the number of patients waiting more than
12 hours for admission
the hospital hit a record in january
that same report found that waiting
times for cancer patients
after referral by their gp were the
worst
on record waiting times for diagnostic
tests
were there were at their highest level
in over a decade
and this was all before the pandemic in
the months since
so many procedures have been delayed
england's waiting list for hospital care
is on track to reach 10 million by the
end of the year
that's more than one-sixth of the
country waiting for care
the number of people in england waiting
longer than 18 weeks for routine care
as it is at its highest level in history
and just yesterday the national health
service
announced that they are going to provide
over the next four years
10 billion pounds to private hospitals
to try and help reduce the waiting times
under the nhs
meanwhile canada faces a backlog for
surgeries
that the government people have even
said or could take them years to get
through
it is true america has its share of
cancelled and rescheduled procedures
since the pandemic began but we didn't
enter this crisis
with record long wait lists and
overcrowded hospitals
in fact the u.s has five times as many
critical
care beds per capita as the united
kingdom
and more than twice as many as in canada
now some might argue that longer weights
are a reasonable price to pay
for the security of single-payer system
would provide
this argument seems especially resonant
during this pandemic
an event that has resulted in mass
joblessness
as well as increased demand for care but
it is important to note that here in the
us
the pandemic hasn't been as devastating
for coverage levels
as many tend to believe while the
pandemic has cost millions of workers
workers their job at tragedy in its own
right many of these americans still have
access to affordable coverage
the commonwealth fund just came out and
said that
2.97 million people who lost their job
have lost their health coverage
the urban institute has given that
number at 3.5
million so not that not very many cobra
is one
option albeit is a pricey one
obamacare's exchanges are an option for
the newly unemployed
people can sign up for obamacare
exchange coverage
outside the normal open enrollment
period if they lose their job
they may even qualify for taxpayer
subsidies
five minutes in five minutes again thank
you
those without any savings and annual
incomes below 138 percent of the federal
poverty level about 17 and a half
thousand
may opt for medicaid others can avail
themselves of the short-term limited
duration insurance plans
which tend to cost far less than the
full price coverage
on the obamacare marketplaces
unfortunately several states of syria
severely restricted access to the
short-term plans
or they found them outright such as in
california and new york
this array of options is one reason
coverage rates have remained relatively
stable
during the crisis an analysis by the
galen institute
estimates that 98 of americans who have
lost their job-based insurance
before the pandemic are still covered
now if what i've said so far is true
and america's current system is superior
to the single-payer alternative
then you make one you might wonder why
56 of the country
favors medicare for all according to the
kaiser family foundation
it's remarkable though how quickly
opinion shifts
once voters learn what single-payer
actually means i.e
only the government that same
kaiser poll found that 58 of americans
oppose medicare for all
if it would eliminate private insurance
companies 60
oppose it if it would raise taxes and 70
would oppose medicare for all if it led
to delays
for even some treatments in other words
medicare for all
stops being popular and americans learn
the truth about it
i'd like to finish my remarks by laying
the
truth in human terms i know consider
some of the stories of many victims of
single-payer health care
68 year old jack webb who died in one of
halifax nova scotia's
largest hospitals a few years ago under
conditions no human being should have to
endure
he arrived in the er department two
weeks after receiving a diagnosis of
pancreatic cancer
he was having trouble breathing his wife
later recalled
that when he was finally seen by a
doctor they were told he was the sickest
man to arrive
that evening yet webb spent the next
five days in agony
because of hospital overcrowding he was
bumped from room to room
occasionally sharing space with several
other patients at one point he spent six
hours in a cold hallway
the night before he died one staffer
callously yelled to another if he stops
breathing
don't resuscitate webb and his family
were in earshot
the whole time think about christina
walker of east sussex england whose son
luis was diagnosed with cystic fibrosis
when he was three weeks old imagine the
hope that his family felt five years ago
when a breakthrough drug or comedy
earned fda approval in the u.s
a drug that could have boosted luisa's
lung function slowed his disease and
improved his quality of life
then imagine how they felt when
britain's cost-effectiveness
body determined that the drug wasn't
worth paying for
one of every 10 people with cystic
fibrosis worldwide
lives in the uk it took four years for
the government to change its mind
or consider one of the more recent
victims of canada's response to the
coving
which led to the blanket of delays for
elective surgeries fifty-year-old chris
walcroft was diagnosed with failing
kidneys last august
he was slated to have surgery mid-march
to prepare him for dialysis
that elective surgery was canceled a
month later
walcroft died on the day he was slated
to finally see a specialist there's one
more victim a single pair i'd like to
highlight
my own mother several years ago she
thought she had colon cancer
she asked her gp for a colonoscopy and
was told
there were too many young people on the
waiting list and she couldn't have one
she had an x-ray which of course doesn't
show colon cancer
after a few months on a waiting list her
condition deteriorated
she went to the hospital in an ambulance
spent two days in the transit lounge
waiting for a bed an award
she did get her colonoscopy but died two
weeks later from metastasized colon
cancer
one minute one minute these events
didn't happen in a war-torn nation or
under
some corrupt authoritarian regime regime
they happen in some of the wealthiest
most advanced economies
in the history of the world and this
could easily happen here
if we insist on following their example
by adopting medicare for all
thank you and so we now go to the
rebuttal
portion five minutes a piece uh jerry
uh you uh have the option of rebounding
take it away jerry okay well thank you
thank you very much sally uh if i may um
that was really interesting um
uh a few points about waitlists
first of all um using oecd
data the share of
americans who are able to get uh
an appointment with the doctor that day
or the next day is 51
it is lower in canada 43
um the uk is uh 57 percent
uh with the nhs so i'm not sure that the
wait list issue really holds
and if you get down to wait list let's
talk about the 33 percent of americans
who report that they were not able to do
a medical procedure this is pre-covet
33 of americans who are not able to do a
medical procedure
are much higher than in canada or
the uk or any other country
the 20 of americans who were not able to
fill a prescription i mean they went to
the doctor and the doctor wrote the
prescription
and they still couldn't do it we're not
even counting all the people
in the united states who did not go to
the doctor because they couldn't afford
it
and that's 10 that's 300 000 by my
estimate 300
000 dead americans um
uh you know when you get to specific
diseases like cystic fibrosis
um you know people in canada live longer
than the united states they live longer
with
most diseases including cystic fibrosis
uh they uh there are gunshot wounds
there are a few cases of
a few cancers where we do better but
the united states is a fabulously
wealthy country the source of much of
the medical innovation that's happened
in the last seven years
most of which by the way has been
financed by the federal government
physicians canada and the united states
and uk all have somewhat fewer
physicians
than other countries in the oecd the
united states is 2.6 physicians per
thousand persons
the uk has 2.8 so there's no evidence
that and canada is 2.6 the same as the
u.s there's no evidence that people are
leaving the medical profession
in canada or the uk unless you want to
say they were also leaving in the united
states at which point we get to which is
worse the burnout of having to deal with
the insulting
insurance industry or lower
lower reimbursement rates get to the
reimbursing rates yes the u.s
doctors are paid a lot but they also
have to pay
for the medical training including all
those student loans that they picked up
they have to pay for the out-of-pocket
course
of dealing with the insurance company
every medical office in the united
states
if you turn your head around past the
receptionist you see these people who
spend
all day some of them trained
professionals
nurses all day talking to the insurance
industry those people are all coming out
of
the reimbursement that goes to the
doctors take
those courses away and american doctors
are not terribly well paid although they
are very well paid in certain
specialties
you know it does vary also of course the
united states everybody's paid more than
in the uk
or even canada which is why we can
recruit so many doc
so many uh economists to come here um
finally uh when you get to the course of
thirteen thousand four hundred dollars
that canadians pay
um out uh out of the tax dollars for
health care
well yeah let's compare apples and
apples i mean
yeah family insurance which does not
cover
everything i mean a decent family
insurance plan with an actuarial value
of around 85 percent
is going to cost you over 18 thousand
dollars in one minute
so americans are paying more
and they're getting worse coverage
as shown by the higher mortality
and the longer wait times and the
greater number of people who are being
denied
access to care i met our health care
system in this country the private
health care system is wasteful
and too expensive thank you jerry
uh five minutes rebuttal for you sally
take it away sally thank you and jerry i
just want to say you know in canada you
pay you can't call up a specialist you
can't call your dermatologist you have
to go through a gp
and that's when you have that weight of
five months between
that and that anyway what i wanted to
say was people like such as yourself
often begin your case by talking about
how wasteful our system is and
inefficient
we do spend more as we've determined
than any other vr as you said a very
wealthy country
yet we don't live as long as our peers
our infant mortality rate is higher
we don't fare as well in international
rankings of systems
made by the points made up by the world
health organization
but data points like these tell us less
about the us health care
system than people like yourself believe
let's look at life expectancy a baby
born in 2017
could expect to live 80 years according
to the cia's world factbook
that's good enough for 43rd take place
worldwide 1.9 years before
behind canada and 0.8 behind the uk but
many of the factors that influence life
expectancy
have nothing to do with health care for
example the us murder rate as of 2016
quadruple great britain's and it's more
than triple candidates
or if you look at car accidents in 2013
the world health organization
estimated that there were more than 34
000
traffic deaths in the u.s on a per
capita basis
there are nearly four times as many
traffic deaths here
in the u.s than in great britain and
nearly twice as many as in canada
many more americans die of drug
overdoses than dupris and canadians
it is a tragedy that we lose so many
americans in the prime of their lives to
drugs or violence
but medicare for all is unlikely to
affect those unfortunate realities
then there is infant mortality you
talked about and written about the fact
that we fare worse than 30 of 35 oecd
nations on this metric but that's in
because in part because there is no
consistent definition of a live
birth across countries some classify
babies who die within
24 hours as miscarriages which are then
excluded from infant mortality
calculations
some european countries require babies
to meet certain height or weight
requirements
to be counted as a live birth according
to the nih
the u.s reports as live births more low
birth weight babies
who are at risk of dying on the first
day and then register those as
infant deaths when a newborn is at risk
there are a few better
places to be than in the u.s only sweden
and norway have better
mortality rates um someone i knew in
calgary alberta was expecting
quadruplets
there wasn't a single neonatal bed in
calgary in edmonton
or in alberta that could deal with these
quads
they were airlifted to great falls
montana a city of 55 000
where the quads were delivered and and
survived the husband these people were
originally south african they said
the canadian healthcare system is that
of a third world country
flawed metrics like life expectancy and
infant mortality
informed the international rankings that
critics of the u.s healthcare system
like to cite indeed the who which places
the united states at number 37
out of 191 countries worldwide bases
one-fourth of its rankings on life
expectancy
another fourth derives from financial
fairness
that practically stats the debt in favor
of government-run systems
which prioritize equity over quality if
we now look at
how people fare when they actually get
sick and need care america's system
performs well
us cancer patients live longer than
those in european countries
thanks in part to higher levels of
spending on cancer care
us patients over the age of 45 who are
admitted to the hospital with a heart
attack or stroke
have a lower 30-day mortality rate than
their peers in other countries
but what about proven 19 this pandemic
has hit our country hard
wouldn't medicare for all have helped
this is by no means clear
countries with government-run systems
have struggled mightily as well
according to the latest stats from johns
hopkins the uk has had
15 18 more cobit deaths per 100
000 people than the us on a per capita
basis basis
britain has had the fifth most coveted
deaths in the world
canada's had roughly half as many deaths
per hundred thousand people as u.s
but our northern neighbors case fatality
rate is more than double hours
the u.s responds to the covet pandemic
has left a lot to be desired
but the same can be said for other
countries government-run healthcare
systems are a bad idea if anything
our health extra healthcare capacity has
helped us compensate
for the shortcomings of our public
health and elected officials
thank you thank you sally
uh we now go to the q a
portion of the evening uh the first
offer to either of you jerry or sally
uh would you at this point like to put a
question
to the other person do you want to wave
that right until later
later uh what do you want to do jerry i
want to wait
right and got a question no i would i
would like to throw a question i'm just
curious what sally
uh has to say um as she notes in her
book
uh 92 of canadians approve of the
healthcare system
um in the uk as well i remember the
opening of the
london olympics and mind you i have
nothing to do with the olympics since
munich
i boycott them but i did hear that
the british put on this big display
about the nhs because as something that
the country is very proud of
um uh if
people in canada and britain are so
proud of their system
or why do you think they're so proud of
their health care system given
um how bad it is in your eyes well i
think
there are a couple of things and the nhs
was a big part of that
of the opening of the uh of the british
olympics which they
won over france which frank the french
were very upset they didn't get
um the um
the um um in in canada
the health care system started to be
taken was start the takeover started in
the 1940s
and then in the 60s it was pretty much
taken over and the
the premier of saskatchewan a ccf
a socialist um was
in charge
named the greatest canadian tommy
douglas um so this was a slow process
completely taken over by 1984. many
people in canada
they don't know anything but the
government running their healthcare
system canadians
my mom um said to me after i'd been in
the us for about 10 years
i hope you're not becoming one of those
impatient americans
americans are impatient canadians and
brits if the doctor says you have to
wait
you know x months then they say well
thank you very much we'll come back
in five months or whatever so there's
that is that is something important they
don't know anything different they're
very nice
but if you look at the fact if you look
at the fact
that people who um need specialized care
the support for the system is is not
strong there was just a poll that just
came out
um uh in our this month in august
which shows that there is a research
company survey that's the name of the
company
that only 30 of canadians think their
system works well
and they 31 said the problem the
problems
the reasons they don't think it works
well is because the long waiting list
26 the shortage of doctors and 55
said many changes are needed to the
canadian health care system we've talked
about
there's going to be 10 million people on
waiting lists in the uk
the national health service just just
today basically they have a cap
on the number of people who've been
trained to be uh doctors and they want
to have that
lifted but the but the reason for not
for having that cap has always been the
cost
of training doctors and the nhs's system
of taking
you know providing planning for these
doctors so
i think and people over 55 in canada
and not the poll numbers have come up
very high about their lack of support
because they can't find specialists and
can't get timely care
so those are those are the main uh
issues that i would say about
uh canada and britain uh sally do you
have a question for jerry or do you want
to wave that right you can exercise it
later do you want to go to my questions
audience questions do you have a
question
uh either way go ahead yes um well i
would i would say about
you know he said millions of people have
lost their
many many millions of people have lost
their coverage well i've looked
you know i looked at the numbers and the
commonwealth fund said 2.97 million
the urban institute said uh 3.5 million
so where what statistic
jerry are you using because we have
about 27 million uninsured in this
country
um seven million were eligible for
medicaid or chip and didn't sign up
eight million were eligible for
obamacare subsidies and didn't enroll so
why are people not enrolling in the
affordable care act which was
in my mind always a precursor to
single-payer
and what about numbers okay well first
of all the numbers that you're giving
are outdated um i've been tracking
weekly new unemployment claims
um and about 40 of people uh who
lose their jobs have had employer-based
coverage
and there are 2.3 people associated with
every person who
has employer-based coverage family
members
so if you multiply 40 by the number of
people who've lost their job
by 2.3 then you get an upper bound
number
for the number who have lost their
coverage now not everybody loses their
coverage right away
some people have a month after and some
people are able to shift onto a spouse
employment based coverage um
some people have gone on to medicaid
which has had expanded goals
but it's um it's an ongoing process now
why don't more people
that eight million who have not taken up
medicaid
includes those who would have been
eligible if the states had expanded
medicaid
the number who have not taken up
medicaid is
in states that have expanded medicaid is
much lower
one thing that happened with the
medicaid expansion under the aca
is the woodwork effect where people who
had been eligible
um you know found realize oh my god i
could have had medicaid
um so that's always an issue the take-up
rate on medicaid
um or other social programs is always an
issue
uh the number of people who have not ins
taken advantage of the aca well you know
a lot of these plans are still pretty
expensive for people
um given the out-of-pocket course i mean
if you have a silver plan
on which your subsidy is based that
leaves you
responsible for 30 of the course um out
of pocket plus
whatever premium you're going to be
paying which may be 3
maybe 5 maybe up to 8 of your
um adjusted gross income um and then
there's you know uh
states that have maintained
the navigators um and the advertising
have had higher take have maintained
higher take-up rates on
the aca exchange plans um than states
would have
is the aca a step toward single payer as
my mother would have said from your
mouth to godzilla i mean i would
i would hope so you would hope not but
right you know
yeah okay you guys can uh
uh return to asking each other questions
shortly we have a number of
a lot of questions coming from the
audience uh
let's uh let me start uh with this one
that's mainly i guess directed to jerry
having to do with your mention of the us
being a huge source of medical
innovation
and the point that's being made is that
that the u.s hugely subsidizes
other healthcare systems through its
medical innovation innovation not only
in drugs
but in procedures and that
that it has something to do with the
fact that
the u.s is more of a market-based
system more capitalists operating for
profit
than these other systems or put in
another way how do you account for the
fact
that the u.s is more market-based and
yet such a huge source
of medical innovation versus the other
medical systems
half of research and development
spending by drug companies
um comes from the federal government the
nsf
the nhs and that includes way
more than half of the truly innovative
research
drug companies count as research and
development their marketing activities
their ever greening activities you know
like adding tylenol to an existing drug
are processes that are often destructive
all they do is extend the patents so
that they can continue to
charge exorbitant prices um the real
research
um for virtually all of the major
medical breakthroughs was financed
through the public sector
that's the answer well i'm getting
another question
related to that are you fearful are you
concerned then
that if the us begins to imitate these
other
medical care health care systems in
other countries that
are that produce far less medical
innovation
that the us will become less of a source
of medical innovation
in the future are you concerned about
that in any way
given the low level of medical
innovation in the
systems that you sponsor i i would
challenge the suggestion that europeans
are much less innovative i mean we spend
a lot on uh medical innovation through
the
the nsf the na nih um through
university research through the
activities of my colleagues and the
north end of campus the science end
and a lot of that goes on elsewhere i
mean if you look at the
many of the most important innovations
and here we can go to canada pre us
canadian single payer frederick banting
and uh what's his name charles but your
best
bet yes yes and what did they get
for that discovery of insulin a dollar
they sold it to the university of
toronto to be given to the world for a
dollar
thank you miguel i'm sorry sorry okay
the salk vaccine in the united states
jonas salt gave it to the world for free
um you know you go on i mean people have
lots of reasons including nobel prizes
that are for um doing
uh innovative research um much of what
is done
for profit is not productive
um adding is an x or a y
to the name of some drug i mean
companies spend
millions on these types of things um and
they mark it up as research and
development course
um so i'm not particularly concerned uh
sally do you have a uh
comment on the question on jerry's
comment
yes i do um so you know
it's interesting that the united states
is a country where all the big
companies come to do the research and
development companies like
glaxosmithkline
uh roach santa fe these companies do not
do their r
d in those countries because those
countries have price controls
and they can't they can't make it so
they do it in the u.s it costs about 2.6
billion dollars
from an idea and a drug to bringing it
to market
only 12 of drugs actually
get through the fda and all the clinical
trials
so you know these other countries we do
sell
you know our top drugs to these other
countries like canada
at a reduced price but these countries
are free riding off our
uh research and development and so that
is
you know these with these countries need
to get rid of their price control so
that they're competing
for competing on a level a level playing
field it's it's
you know when you look at the vaccine um
vaccines that are being in it you know
research now for covid19 most of them
whether it's pfizer whether it's j and j
modern of the vaccine the vaccine trials
that are going well
are being you know done developed by
major companies but mr trump did sign an
executive order to help
private public partnerships to make this
this go
go faster and and remdezabeer the drugs
from gilead
which is has proved use very effective
in hospital situations they're providing
it for three thousand dollars for five
uh treatments um you know they're
they're selling it at
not at their cost at all but at three
thousand dollars to help people
um get better but we really need to
these other countries need to get
stopped free riding off our r d canada
has the the patented medicines crisis
review board a lot of the new drugs that
are available here
that are the are the pharmaceutical
companies are willing to sell to canada
at lower prices
the patented medicine prices review
board doesn't even allow them in
because they say the price is still too
high so i want to keep the market
open for innovation research and
development
because it'll keep us out of the
hospital and as um the
frank lichtenberg at columbia said for
every one dollar spent on newer
pharmaceuticals
we save seven dollars and 17 cents in
hospital costs
so let's keep that market open i'm
getting older i want to be able to have
access i'm sure jerry does too
the latest and i don't like hospitals
and actually i don't like going to
doctors either
getting questions it challenges you
sally
to you sally uh different related
questions
uh i guess people are taking umbrage at
your idea
that the u.s healthcare system is a
market-based system
because one of the questions is uh
to what extent would you reform uh
the u.s healthcare system to make it
more market-based
in particular the the employer-based
health
care which was uh which was an ironic
result of world war
ii where government companies were
giving this out
to what extent do you think it's really
not a market-based system
to what extent would you make it more so
in order to
address some of jerry's concerns that's
your question sally
oh okay good well um certainly it is not
a free market system really because 50
of our health care system is already in
the hands of government in this country
i talked about
65 million on medicaid 60 million on
medicare we have a lot of kids on the
on the chip program for low-income
children and of course the veterans
administration
50 of our health care is already in the
hands of government
so americans like competition we have
competition in all aspects of our life
except for really in health care so the
things you know you mentioned
gene that during world war ii when wagen
price controls were in
the government gave employers the
ability to write off the cost
of providing health care to their
employees and the employees
get their health care tax-free if you
lose your job or you put your job you go
into the individual market you have to
buy your health care uh in in the
individual market
and you have to pay based on tax on tax
income we need to change that so
individuals
can get their health care uh tax-free um
as well we also need to open up things
which is actually opening up now because
of the pandemics such as telehealth
where you know people can do talk to
their doctor
over the internet rather than having to
find a car service or
or or get on the bus the train during
the pandemic so telehealth is a great
idea
scope of practice we need to let more
nurse practitioners and physicians
assistants
do things that they can do doctors don't
need to that will reduce help reduce
costs
i think medical school could be reduced
from four years down to three
it would be cheaper and it doesn't have
to be four years um unc
chapel hill is doing that duke is trying
that and so
there's a lot of things that need to be
done medicare and medicaid
you no those programs uh um came into
being in 1965
under lyndon johnson and his great
society well
you know the average life expectancy in
65 was age 65. today
the average uh medicare recipient lives
to age um
79 and a half and so medicare needs to
be reformed
they've already said that medicare
trustees it'll be bankrupt by 2029
medicare part a
so let's um you know do some means
testing why should people like
um you know warren buffett even be
eligible for medicare medicare should be
there for those seniors
who really need it so we need to raise
the age of eligibility
means test it and then on medicaid the
program that you know for low-income
americans and
um and people with disabilities um that
program
is is very expensive and as we've seen
you know
one in three new medicaid eligible
patients can't even find a doctor
because the reimbursement rates are so
low so i'd like to see some opening up
of the system
in medicaid so that there are like hmos
for people on medicaid
we need to expand health savings
accounts it's a great way 27 million
people now of hsas
people should be able to contribute to
their hsa after age 65 and
now you can't do that and um the amounts
that you can put into your account
uh should be should be greater and you
should be able to use your hsa to help
pay for your premium
there's all kinds of got
jerry i want you to respond but then i
want to throw in a question
that's sort of related to this just to
spice it up
you seem to have suggested maybe this is
where
you would sell the converge that you
actually would provide some private
option for people
so therefore you've got a private sector
uh
affection sinking into your viewpoint
and
oh but of course how would you respond
to jerry and how would you respond to
the private
option that you think is of some value
take it away jerry oh uh well i
absolutely think that it's essential
that we preserve some private
competition
or a private option um that as
happens in the uk and as basically
happens in every
every country with uh socialized health
insurance
um in canada that private option is
sometimes the united states
um and i think that it's really
important that people have
an escape valve um now obviously this is
a safe
an escape valve that only the privileged
affluent
will be able to get um i wish everybody
could live in amherst and i wish
everybody
could have the opportunities that
somebody of my income could have
um but i think that it's important that
people
be able to get out from under an
insurance company
or a government um that is uh being
overly restrictive
um now competition oh
no no there is no competition to speak
of i mean
um what's the competition to mass
general hospital
there is none um and this is the point
that kenneth arrow was making
50 years ago oh god i'm getting old 60
almost 60 years ago
um that because of uncertainty and
asymmetric information
people rush to um
brand names um and there are
patent protections for ensure for the
drugs
um there are there's word of mouth
that's why mass general is able to
charge four times as much
as other hospitals in massachusetts um
and when i said this once to a meeting
of the uh
a conference of the heads of research
and teaching hospitals
the head of mass general uh partners um
came to me very angry that we're not a
monopoly we don't
overcharge you got to compare us to
johns hopkins
it's like okay yeah johns hopkins is
another of these brand names
so there isn't really competition there
is just monopoly rents
you you own hospitals like mass general
or johns hopkins there's
kind of one in every state or two in
every state if you're lucky
and those guys are raking in billions
the boss the city of boston is being
bought up
by the profits being generated by mass
general and it's getting
worse and that they can't do it to
medicare
but they do it to private health
insurance and they are buying up
hospitals throughout new england
and closing them down to shift the
patients
to boston where they can charge more at
mass general
um medicare and medicaid already have
and i think this is a mistake but they
already have
very large private elements you can't
say that half of the american health
care is public
because of medicare medicaid etc
medicare advantage has about a third of
the people on medicaid
on medicare and almost every medicaid
system in the country um has an hmo
uh component and in many everyone is
immediately put into the hmos
so there already is um you know uh
we're already chipping away at the uh um
uh public sector uh finally just this is
a small point but
as an economic historian it's one that
always bothers me and it bears on the
competition thing
it wasn't the irs that did it
employer-based healthcare goes back to
united states steel international
harvester even before world war one
employers pushed employer-provided
health insurance so they could get
control over their workers and i think
this is an
area where sally and i would agree
that the employer-based system um it's
not only
wasteful but it it's intended
to lock workers into uncompetitive
situations giving their employer a
monopsonistic power
ability to drive down wages and exploit
the workers
um uh so you know we that's one area
where we would agree and we would agree
with the
people in the in the obama
administration who are really hoping the
exchanges would become
a way to destroy employer-based
insurance
um we spend in tax subsidies close to
400 billion dollars
on employer subsidizing employee-based
coverage in this country
if we could that's another area which
she and i i think would agree
do away with that subsidy um and you
know but anyway i'll stop there
yeah uh the related question came in uh
jerry
now back to you that uh the uh the term
of
apparently not being used by the uh by
the here but
uh aren't there rules that require
that if you're going to open up a
hospital that the ability to do so has
got to be reviewed by the other
hospitals
and isn't that that would be like if
you're going to open up a delicatessen
then all the other delicatessens have to
review your application
and establish the need if there's
something that community need
would you roll back that regulation in
order to
uh to incur to allow entry into the
into this market would you which are the
certificate of need
it's called yes do you feel that's
that's a government regulation that's an
enemy of competition
uh well it would be if you thought that
uh
um you know opening a new hospital is
going to promote competition
um which you know i hospitals are very
expensive to establish
i don't know how much we would want to
rely on it
uh that element of competition with uh
we're getting fewer and fewer hospitals
in this country and i don't think it's
because of certificate of need
um i think it's because of these
hospital networks buying up the company
the other hospitals and driving patients
to the more expensive
urban teaching settings um i don't
i haven't really looked into the
certificate of need issues so i'm going
to punt on that one
whether we'd want to i just want i just
want to just make a couple of points
because i think
you know certificate of need for all the
hospitals in that area to have to
approve
if jerry if you want to set up a
cardiology hospital if they decide they
don't if they want to keep a cardiology
business in their hospital they can
direct i think that is wrong i think we
need
we need all kinds of different hospitals
and under obamacare you know
new um specialized hospitals were banned
we're also also we're seeing a huge
reduction in rural hospitals
and you know for people in rural areas
who are older you know this is why
telehealth is a good
um thing because these people can't
can't get to the doctor or maybe can't
even get the very best doctor
so certificate of need i think law
should be and a lot of
economists have agreed with that but i
think you know in the aca
we um you know overturned the health
care system with the affordable care act
and there are only
right now uh 10 million people on the
exchanges 87
of them are getting subsidies you can
earn up to 400 percent of the federal
poverty level
but but you know what really you know
the the average
silver plan uh this year was 467 dollars
a month a lot of people
you know that are in that individual
place but they can't afford 467 uh
dollars a month and that's why you know
that the buy-in to it was not good but
i as i say i do see it is where terry
and i different i do see it as a
stepping stone approach
just like i do with a public option that
joe biden
you know is talking about having a
government insurance plan to compete
against private insurers my view is
the the government will lower um have a
lower price for the health care
and you know then it will crowd out
private insurers and it's just more of a
stepping stone approach
to medicare for all uh yeah thanks
we have time for uh one more question
i'm getting a lot coming to you jerry so
i'm gonna
a lot of uh the the the uh question here
uh a couple of questions uh relating to
this
uh that the examples where uh
uh institutions are operate uh medical
institutions operate
in a basically free market lasik surgery
of course is a classic when used
lower prices high quality oklahoma
surgical center
doesn't accept insurance operates in a
very free market
and the idea is that that all of the the
the ideas
that were propounded about how this is
not going to work because it's free
market
the uh that original uh uh research
paper
seems to be believed by these examples
of
operating the totally free market lasik
surgery for example
oklahoma surgery center for example how
do you explain
that phenomenon in terms of your
framework
lasik surgery as a model for
um health care in the united states uh
you know i i don't buy it i mean if you
don't have the money to lay for lasik
surgery
um you don't get it i don't care whether
or not you have lasik surgery
or wear glasses or um you know as long
as you don't go driving with bad vision
um it there's not much of a public good
aspect there there is a public good in
your ability to be healthy
what do you say is this the oklahoma
surgical center which is another and
perhaps you don't know
that yeah much lower prices that are
transparent
that does surgery of all kinds
operations all right anyway go ahead
you can't take um you know
transparency and prices is something
that is worth almost nothing
um because most people don't know what
what going in you don't know what you're
going to need
um and you don't know the quality of the
service that you're going to be getting
i mean that's
that's where arrows making his case
uh it's the unknowns and the unknowns
that
you don't even know what they are uh you
go to the doctor
um you know i'm seeing these lights on
the side of my eyes
uh side of my peripheral vision um and
you know so i googled it
at night and secular degeneration
macular degeneration
degeneration i hope not i i see that
so anyway i don't really know what it is
i googled it i'll be seeing the eye
doctor
the uh you know you don't know going
into it and that's why people buy
insurance you buy insurance because you
don't know
um and and it's something that you'll be
needing
so okay uh sally you want to address
that question briefly that uh that jerry
just
i think direct primary care you're
talking about oklahoma surgery center
there's a couple of
thoughts it's direct primary care and
that is a way to reduce costs and people
to be able to get good primary care
through through this
uh process i think it's really
interesting that 49
of young docs are now joining hospitals
rather than going into
private or a small group practice but we
want to support
direct primary care and get doctors to
you know see patients at a
at a price you know they can do mris a
lot cheaper than if you go
to say you uh the mass general and get
the price that you get at mass general
would be probably three times as much
as you get at the as you'd pay at the
oklahoma surgery center
we need to have all kinds of different
um
ideas and systems because that's what
makes america great not pushing people
into one size fits all
okay uh we have only about 20 seconds
left to the q and a
portion so i think i better stop and
then a portion you both an extra 10
seconds
for your summaries and then so uh
uh jerry uh you go first you have seven
and a half minutes
to summarize yeah take it away jerry
okay
well um you know i'd like to think about
children
because children come into this world
completely unable to pay for what they
need
we hope that parents will help them um
if you're smart and lucky you'll be born
to a parent who's able to
afford the care you need but what if you
don't
or what if you're born with some
degenerative disease what if you're born
with some genetic condition
um you know who's going to take care of
you
and are we ready to let those children
die
now that's maybe i was saying it
strongly but let's leave out death let's
just talk about
are we going to let those children grow
in a society
where they will be unproductive because
they lacked the health care that they
needed
to grow up productive um
if your parents don't have the money or
if your parents are selfish then what's
going to happen to those children
you know at the beginning of life you
have the children
at the end of life you have medicare
and you have the elderly now why did we
get medicare for the elderly
we it came in for the elderly because
there was
no functioning insurance market for the
elderly
health insurance was not being sold to
the elderly because
they were going to be too expensive to
care for and there's too much
variation in the
life situation and the health situation
of the elderly
the insurance companies assumed that if
you were looking for insurance
you were going to need it you knew that
you would need it they couldn't tell
or they would go in and assume
that well maybe you're okay now but
there's a lot of variation of what's
going to happen for the elderly so they
would have to price their health
insurance at a high rate
um to cover the risk so there was no
functioning insurance market for the
elderly
um children could not buy insurance for
themselves they could not buy health
care for themselves so there was no
functioning
healthcare market for the children
except
you know those who were lucky enough so
what do we have
we have a health care system that is
already a free market healthcare system
that's already going to be restricted to
you know i'll say between late teens and
50s yeah and within that
people with pre-existing conditions um
people who have
degenerative discs people who have
cancers people who have had cancers and
it may come back
you know so you know the free market for
health care
starts getting smaller and smaller and
smaller
and then you get to the provider side
you've got the haas
the elite hospitals that are able to
jack up their prices because of brand
names
they're able to buy increasingly buying
up other hospitals
to drive away competition
we have monopolies on that side and we
have a failure
of the ability to buy
insurance and buy health care on the
other side altogether
you don't have a free market and you
never have a free market in health care
what you have are varying degrees
of imperfect competition
or imperfect markets in healthcare and
then the question becomes
how do we want to handle that do we want
to
promote an impossible
free market moving in that direction
what economists would call
second best economics which kevin
lancaster and others showed
you know at least in theory is not
necessarily the best way to go um
and your arrows another one who worked
in that area
um you know what you want to do is
choose the best option available while
keeping in mind that governments make
mistakes
god we know that in the united states
these days
governments make mistakes and we want to
have you have to
allow for that as most countries do that
have
single payer type health care systems so
given that
you know you could subsidize people to
go into the private sector
subsidize children subsidize medicare um
and just let the market go give every
elderly person a
chunk of money well that's not going to
work very well because that's not
dealing with the monopoly on the other
side the monopoly of the hospitals the
monopoly of the health of the drug
companies
and the monopolies that would spring up
because everybody does want insurance so
if you don't
provide it to the public sector they'll
be buying it
uh they'll try to buy it from the
private sector
or you could do the cost effective thing
provide medicare for everybody where
medicare
is able to use its monopsonistic power
to beat down the rent seeking
by monopolistic hospitals and
monopolistic drug companies
while providing the health insurance
that all
or the health care that all americans
need now of course
there are limits to what we can do
and government agencies like nice and
britain
will be decided we'll be making those
decisions
through the political process your
democratic process we hope to put
constraints on that
we need to leave a safety valve for
people
um you know people who have particular
medical needs that are being neglected
um you know you know we need to be
you know we need to admit that we may
not
be always be making the right decisions
and government
needs to be accommodated but that said
the fundamental principle is there that
we have
that as a decent society and as a
society that's concerned about the
productivity of its people
and as a society that wants to limit
monopoly
power one minute generally yeah we need
to have
a strong government role in medicaid in
health
healthcare
and that's what medicare for all is all
about i'll yield my time
thank you okay thank you jerry uh
sally seven and a half minutes of your
summary take it away
sally but some of the most powerful
arguments against government-run
healthcare
are the stories of those who've been
victimized by it take the case of jamie
lee ball who in march of 2017 arrived at
ontario's brampton civic hospital
in excruciating pain according to the
canadian broadcasting corporation she'd
undergone
abdominal surgery the previous month and
knew her condition might be serious
soon after she arrived a doctor
determined she was bleeding internally
and might need a blood transfusion but
she spent five days in a stretcher
on a stretcher in a hallway screaming in
pain and crying
the hospital had declared a code
gridlock meaning in canada that it had
no
if the hospital was at capacity and no
longer able to put patients in beds
at one point she was booted from her
prime spot
in the hallway to accommodate a cancer
patient she told the cbc that everyone
shared a single public bathroom
virtually every canadian knows someone
who has a story
like jamie lee's but it's no wonder and
jerry even
mentioned this that as many as 323 000
canadians out of a population of 36
million
go abroad to obtain medical care um
because
they find the waiting list is too long
and and they meet and they are in pain
they want to get um good care
in a in a reasonable time and canada's
leaders know their health care system is
failing
claude castane the so-called father of
quebec's medicare system said
we thought we could resolve the system's
problems by rationing services or
injecting massive amounts of public
funding into it
40 years after installing single-payer
he proposed to give a greater role to
the private sector
so that people can exercise freedom of
choice
yet the progressive wing of the
democratic party seems uninterested in
learning from canada and great britain's
mistake
senator sanders has been to medicare for
all bills
contemplate a level of public spending
that goes far beyond massive
both the libertarian leading mercatus
center and the left-leaning urban
institute
estimate that the increase in federal
spending under medicare for all
would be between 32 and 40 trillion
dollars
over 10 years and that estimate is the
best case scenario
in all likelihood medicare for all would
cost far more
and that's because if healthcare became
free at the point of service
americans would demand more of it we
heard an uh economist at mit
amy finkelstein has has pointed uh
that out remember medicare came into
being along with medicaid in 1965.
um the president um lyndon johnson said
it would cost about uh a billion dollars
in the first year 12 billion dollars in
1990
medicare in 1990 cost 110 billion
dollars
these government programs will cost so
much more
but let's accept the case scenario and
assume a cost of 32 trillion over 10
years
it's far from clear where that money
would come from it would have to come
from new taxes
because um as as we've heard
from economists like charles way house
even if you
doubled all the personal income taxes
and corporate income taxes it wouldn't
be
it wouldn't cover the cost of this
single payer and a recent proposal by
senator sanders markey and
pierson gilligrand in type they
introduced the medic
billionaires pay act the bill would
impose a one-time 60
tax on money made by billionaires during
the pandemic
this wouldn't raise enough money to
cover medicare for all there just aren't
enough
millionaires and billionaires to cover
in wealth taxes
um new payroll taxes new income taxes
taxes on financial institutions
they would come up short what this means
is that the middle class americans not
just the wealthy
would have to see their taxes rise
substantially
under medicare for all and senator
sanders has admitted that we saw in the
poll
numbers i gave that support goes way
down for medicare for all
to about 37 if it means increased taxes
and it means losing your your
employer-based coverage
now massive tax increases might put a
damper on the economy during good times
just imagine how much damage they did
during a period the story of historic
joblessness
such as we're facing today now some
might suggest that americans would no
longer pay insurance premiums
these new taxes would be a wash but
according to ken thorpe from emory
university
more than seven in ten households with
private insurance
would pay more under a single-payer
system than they do under the canadian
under the current system
and let's not discount another kind of
cost of medicare for all
that it would impose on americans if the
experience of canada and the uk are any
indication
patients would lose access to many of
the new medicines that we have access to
in this country
of the 243 new medicines launched
between 2011 and 2018
just two-thirds were available in the uk
even fewer were available in canada
88 were on offer here in the u.s
this disparity in access to cutting-edge
treatment helps explain why the u.s
has better five-year survival rates for
the most common forms of cancer
breast stomach prostate rectal and
ovarian
than in canada and in the uk stats like
that back up one of my favorite quips
about britain's national health service
from a writer at the guardian the only
serious black mark against the nhs
was its poor record on keeping people
alive
medicare for all would not just reduce
access to cutting-edge treatments here
at home
it would have global implications and
ramifications for medical innovation
the united states is an indispensable
source of funding
for research into new drugs therapies
and vaccines
if americans began underpaying for drugs
the whole enterprise of drug development
would become economically infeasible the
result would be fewer new drugs
for treating cancer alzheimer's heart
disease and even covid19
this brings me back to the resolution at
hand because covid19 is the clearest
example
of the dangers of underfunding medical
innovation
so much of the promising work towards
curing this disease
is happening right here in the u.s i
talked about pfizer
j j moderna um astrazeneca in the uk
working with university of oxford
and that's because our somewhat
market-based healthcare system
has given rise to a vibrant
well-resourced research ecosystem
the ecosystem could not survive under a
single-payer system
and like in europe and in canada
so medicare for all would make it harder
not easier
to meet the challenges of this pandemic
it would leave
us tragically unprepared for future
public health crises
it would impose crippling costs on our
government and the economy
and it would make the pain and
indignities indignity suffered by
canadians
and everyday occurrence michael buble
the great great canadian singer from
vancouver where i'm from
and his son at age three in vancouver
was diagnosed
with uh liver cancer he didn't wait to
see what would
how he could have treated candy we went
to universe children's hospital in l.a
had it treated and five and five years
later he is cancer-free he said we had
the best doctors
the best specialists and this is what we
want to keep
america open for thank you okay
uh thank you sally you you came in after
a few seconds under as well
uh jane please open
the final vote and uh interrupt me
once the final vote is in
meanwhile a couple of announcements uh
our next online debate will take place
on wednesday september 9th the debate
resolution will be
to combat inequality greater investments
must be made in public schools
so as not to accommodate the formation
of
pandemic pods by affluent parents
defending that resolution will be
the university of south carolina
professor john dale
opposing the resolution corey d'angelos
of the reason foundation but don't try
to buy tickets yet
it will take us a few days to have this
event
posted uh in addition uh
instead of watching kamala harris this
evening you might prefer to catch
last month's three-way solar form debate
on the coming presidential election in
which
three different libertarians advocated
for biden
trump or joe jorgensen uh so far
uh that debate has had more than 36 000
views on youtube and i'm sure jerry and
sally
your debate is going to have a huge
audience so tonight we just get
uh the crowd that's around us but of
course the largest audience
is to come and that's just youtube views
uh that doesn't include
our podcasts uh i had a debate with uh
gerald's uh jerry's uh former colleague
richard wolff
that set the record of 1.2 million views
uh jerry
see if you can do better than richard
wolff did
exit never compete okay
all right so the gloves are off but
sally is gonna put you over the top
jerry so that's
and so that's going to be the 1.2
million that you'll both have
and so uh in addition i should mention
i was on the tom woods show podcast
debating
david stockman last week former budget
director under ronald reagan
on the economic one might say i played
optimus to david's pessimist
you can access this debate by googling
the tom woods show
uh in addition i also appeared on the
free man beyond the wall podcast
and gave host pete quinones a granular
account
of how things are going at the epicenter
otherwise known
as new york city pete calls the episode
new york city has reached herd immunity
according to gene epstein
you can access that by googling free man
beyond
the wall we're also grateful for the
generous support uh these people are
being paid
big bucks five hundred dollars a piece
to do what they just did
and that's a pretty big wage you know
two dollars there's a 250 in an hour
we assume you didn't come in at all
prepared so therefore
it's just basically paying for you you
for your time on
air and that's 500 bucks that comes from
the smith
family foundation to which we're very
grateful
and for administrative and technical
support we get the reason foundation
uh jane uh is the voting close jane are
you there hello
did you email me the results jane where
did where is it
why i'm sorry oh there were you okay
okay let's see now
uh all right now on voting uh
all right uh voting yes on the
resolution uh
pre was 20 in favor as you know it's who
moves the needle
and jerry you picked up six point six
and three quarters points
you went to twenty six point seven
percent so congrats
gary yeah but then the marks of that was
the number to beat six point
six seven percent sally went from sixty
percent
to 73.2 so she picked up 13.3 points
uh sally you get the tootsie roll
uh and uh but uh it was uh beautifully
done by all of you
both of you i should say thank you to
you both
and good night to all and we hope to see
you at the next debate indeed
we hope to see you at the subculture
theater in downtown new york for a
physical debate an old 20th century
debate
uh once we can return to our si to our
physical space at the subculture theater
thanks jerry and sally
and good night